joining me now is former lioness and
talksport presenter Leanne Sanderson who
has 50 caps for the England team and as
well the last time England won a trophy
was in 1966 and I'm totally shocked I'm
a massive fan Sir Jeff Hurst joins me
from that team right now Sir Jeff uh
good evening sir how are you
I'm okay thank you very well thank you
you've got to start more excited than
that man it's amazing
well I'm not excited listen I'm not
excited now all right I'm very excited
yesterday uh it was absolutely fantastic
let's start Leanne you were there
weren't you
um there's been loads of talk today and
I get it about what this means for
women's football let's just talk about
the atmosphere inside Wembley 87 000
people more than watch them man let's
get it in there what was it what was it
like the atmosphere it was amazing I've
been fortunate enough to be at every
single game commentating for talksport
and it was just an amazing atmosphere
all the stadiums whether it be Brighton
Sheffield but yesterday was incredible
and I've never had so many ticket
requests for a game I genuinely believe
it could have sold out like three times
over and I've always said seeing is
believing and if you advertise something
people will come and people laugh when I
say this I love Beyonce I don't just go
to the O2 hoping she's going to turn up
you know and wait I think we didn't
advertise the women's game in this
country ever in the last six months you
know TV Outlets radio stations have
taken hold of you know women's football
in this country and everybody can see it
and now they have role models to look up
to now role models were there before but
at the same time nobody could visibly
see them one FA Cup Final that I played
in a year was on TV and now all the
games are on television and people could
make their own assessment of the players
individually and I think that's what's
amazing I was there yesterday yeah I
cried at the end because I was so
emotional genuinely because I just felt
like I've been there you know I've
played in the final 2009 when we lost to
Germany six two you know I've lost at
Wembley to Germany three nil so it was
just so great for all the players my
former teammates and it was brilliant so
Jeff um I read this amazing quote from
you sir you're the only man to score a
hat-trick in a World Cup final uh when
Chloe Kelly scored an extra time you
tweeted amazing holding breath uh
followed by European Champions
unbelievably proud what was it like for
you sir Jeff watching that yesterday
well the strangest thing is probably
more excited watching a great game like
that than probably playing in the final
because when you're playing in the game
you're so uh focused on the on the game
itself you're not aware of the
atmosphere or the tension really it's
when you actually become a fan and
you're watching it that you get quite
excited and I was a genuinely excited as
every other fan in the country not the
people at Wembley of course but the
people all over the country you look at
you know Trafalgar Square it was
absolutely magnificent and you can
become aware of the the important the
importance I think I think what what
Leanne said as well Sir Jeff you know 17
and a half million people watch that
match and this this sort of building
Crescendo in the country I'll be
perfectly honest sort of until it got to
the quarterfinal stage I was probably
your architect well I'm a West damn
first so Jeff and I got something in
common 14 years 58 to 72 I know he's a
legend but the fact is it sort of
started to interest me and then the
Spain game and then the semi-final
against Sweden and and it it just built
and and I actually suggest Leanne's
right the interest the turnout today
phenomenal what does that do do you
think for female women's football in the
future
oh it's it's tremendous inspiration even
uh before the result in the final a
major step forward getting to get into a
final it was already going to inspire
many many young girls in this country
whether we'd won or lost but now going
on to win it of course it is absolutely
magnificent I I recall 20 years ago I
went to short five women at a introduced
him to the level one coaching course and
four of the five women where we had a
cup of tea afterwards said they were
barred from playing football so we have
you cannot believe how much we have
moved on and this this win yesterday is
another giant step for women's football
and for young girls to be inspired to to
get involved in playing football at four
or five years of age fantastic
completely agree Serena vegman the the
manager fascinates me I've got some
facts here we talk about how you know
female football now will will move
forward
um Gareth Southgate earns 5 million quid
a year Serena vegman owns 400 Grand
right the average wage of a of a of a
professional footballer for a female in
England is 30 grand and the average
Premier League wage is 60 Grand a week
can you see that moving because of this
because of TV money because of interest
because all of my kids everybody was
totally into it yeah and I think
eventually you know they'll have to get
with the times because the U.S women's
national team you know I've just got
equal pay a lot of the countries all
over the world have I think ultimately
it comes down to revenue and I think
they've seen now they can bring in the
revenue the sponsorships are there and
everybody wants to be on board and it's
been a fantastic tournament for that and
you know I think obviously I get asked
that question a lot about equal pay and
the fact that I make more money now
doing TV work than I've ever did playing
football is quite sad at the end of the
day isn't it because I retired two years
ago and make more money now let's be
honest let's go to the shows you must be
absolutely gutted to have missed I
always think all those Premiership
footballers ago he's on 300 Grand a week
I wish I hadn't retired but but you're
proud of where the game is but you feel
like you missed the boat a bit no
because I still work in the men's game
now and work in the women's game and you
know I'm still involved do we need we
don't need to talk about that yeah man
united to get out
so in man united man now listen let's
talk West Ham what an extraordinary
couple of years we've had under the
moisaya can you see West Ham you know
getting there into the Champions League
come on let's give it a bit of a plug
well I actually amazed you want to talk
about West Ham United after the ladies
winning the tournament yesterday
very happy to talk about West Ham of
course
oh fine okay well I'm happy to talk
about West Ham particularly when we do
well I very rarely talk to uh
journalists about West Ham when things
haven't been going through it you go
back two years need a relegated so it's
been an absolutely uh again a
magnificent scene a season for the
Amazon the David Morris I think the
recruitment prior in prior to that a
couple years ago wasn't very good he's
turned it all around and a great run in
Europa League vying for that top four
for most of the Season it was always
going to be slightly out of our reach
yeah where we've come from nearly
relegated two years ago it's a
magnificent step forward and the reason
it is you know sixty thousand sixty
thousand people now at the ground it's
it's a magnificent time for the Hammers
the reason I actually did that genuinely
was because the apathy around West Ham
as a West Ham fan up to a couple of
years ago you could almost level a
female football women's football because
I promise you four four weeks ago I
didn't it didn't resonate I I one of the
things I thought well yeah I watched the
women's game not really if I'm being
complete greatly honest I'll tell you
one thing women don't do when they get
tackled they get straight up they don't
squeal like men do I mean they just are
to me but it's a lot of people like you
Jeremy that are around the country that
felt that way and you can be honest I
mean people come up to me and say they
whether they like the game or not I
don't really care at the end of the day
what I know is this lionesses have done
an unbelievable job in the way they've
won we didn't win you know I did pave
the way loads of players passed away
before me but ultimately these lionesses
have won and it is changing you know
people's perceptions of the women's game
and stereotypes and we're not trying to
be the men we're not trying to compete
with the men we're trying to do I said
you don't have Serena Williams against
Federer do you no compare the two I mean
don't compare us I think it was Lord
sugar I could be wrong I'd be told if it
was he said it's just Pub football it's
never going to be the same women's
football can you see a female football
team what level of men's would it be the
championship would it be League one what
do you reckon yesterday's team the
European Champions it's difficult you
can't draw comparisons because we used
to play when I played for England
against Academy players yeah and they're
just quicker and stronger genetically so
that you can't even compete really they
that's a genuine truth and people say to
me oh you know Leanne you should be
playing in the men's game no I shouldn't
because if we're doing a Rondo like a
6v2 yeah if I'm shooting on a goalkeeper
yes but when it comes to 11v11 like they
just hit the wall over our head right
onto it and just genetically they're
quicker um so Jeff is one of the
greatest Strikers this country has ever
seen that World Cup hat trick will stay
in folklore forever what did you make of
Ella Tunes finish I thought it was one
of the coolest chips I've ever seen in
my life under pressure
that was absolutely Top Class wasn't it
I mean what can you say about it it was
it wasn't a chip it was almost like a
half volley flicked over I mean
absolutely perfect and you wouldn't get
a better finish we talk about not
comparing men and women naturally of
course in the game but you would not get
a better finish from a man than that
goal it was absolutely fantastic and
what a great way to open the account and
you only think about Russo's back heel
in the semi-final I mean that I mean if
with respect if a man had done that
they'd be saying that's better than Pele
it was extraordinary wasn't it
yes it was I will say two things about
that that's probably I'm not being
patronizing to women here or against men
that was probably the best back hill I
think I've ever seen in any class of
football I agree against that I would
say I think the goalkeeper probably was
felt a little bit regretful of letting
it go through her legs as unexpected as
it was
so Jeff you're very kind I really
appreciate you joining us and Leanne
last word from you you talk about what
this means what do you hope it means for
the future for women's football in the
world in the United Kingdom I hope it
changes I hope it's here to stay you
know when I played at Wembley before
there was 70 000 now we go to
borehamwood when I play for Arsenal
there'd be 300 people there so I
encourage people like I have done all
day go out buy a season ticket for a wso
club wso2 because we need you there we
need the funding and stuff like that but
the women's football is here to stay and
hopefully people like yourself have been
changed during this talk and that
couldn't happen you can take me to a WSL
game now anything for a free ticket
Leanne sanderson's Jeff Hurst thank you
very much indeed the amazing lionesses
winning and are now European Champions